now to be fair now be fair okay
they do like
at my house i'm the one who scares the
easiest
i'm the one i'm the one who scares the
easiest they scare me
and just so you know like at my house
when you practically joke somebody when
you get somebody you say gotcha
and they've all tried to get me back and
the only person that's never got me back
was jakey
and he's not he's always like i've
always just wanted to say got you i've
always wanted to say got you just got
you
and you can't look man he's not he's
first of all he's too nice
he's too nice like you can't get me with
food i grew up with three older brothers
if you're too excited for me to eat
something there's no [ __ ] way i'm
eating that
he's tried to get me before with a
brownie he was like you want this
brownie
are you laughing
you can't get me in a room because guess
who's not going into the room first me
i never go into her if someone's like go
in i'm like [ __ ] are you going
no i don't and here's another thing
i'm hard to prank because
i i know what my daily routines are
and if if something is bumped off i take
a mental note of it if more than one
thing is bumped off i assume somebody's
coming for me
[Music]
does anybody did anybody grow up in a
youngest of a big family
yo there's some ptsd that comes along
with that [ __ ]
so all right so i i don't trust anybody
in here okay
and so
this was his greatest attempt for the
go-to
one day i'm at the house
and with beth and jacob was 15.
and
she goes i'm gonna go pick up jacob i
said all right by the way red flag
number one
she hated that [ __ ] line
she never went to pick him up she was
like i hate waiting in that line i hate
and i'm like yeah i didn't mind doing it
you know
so mental note number one i was like
what not that big of a bump because
maybe she just wants to get something
planned with jakey whatever right
so then five minutes later there's a
knot
on my door
and i open it and it's a younger dude
and uh oh you're one of those guys
and i see a couple of you guys out there
oh
um and so
i go can i help you and he's got a
clipboard he goes yeah i'm
jacob wolf's tutor
red flag number two how come i don't
know he has a tube
and i go who who who orders a tutor he
said it doesn't say but it says i'm
supposed to ask for josh red flag number
three hey guess what guys
you know who my wife doesn't let me talk
to
people who come to the door
i like to [ __ ] with people too much i
i've really like i've had plumbers
electricians leave mid-job
because i thought it'd be fun to [ __ ]
around and they're like this is not good
you know
[Music]
so i know for sure she's not calling a
tutor and having me answer the door so
right away i'm like this
stinks
now i will tell you something else if i
think i'm sniffing out a joke i'm gonna
pull one on you before you can pull one
on me
i just am i'm gonna get you before it to
me it's a game and it always has been so
to me this guy and i'm i need to test to
see if this dude's
on the payroll you know and so i go i go
well they're not here i said do you want
to come in and wait and he said would
that be okay i said yeah
so he comes in
and look there are a couple things that
people who aren't in on the joke real
people
aren't going to do but if you're in on
the joke you're going to play along with
everything that i'm doing because you
feel like you have to you know
so i go to the guy hey i go i was about
to head to the gym so i'm going to go
change and i'll be right out i go grab a
seat on the couch and he said okay so
grab seat on the couch and i come out in
spandex shorts like to hear
and a half shirt
and i start stretching out in front of
this dude like this
oh the baby bird was out of a nest you
know what i mean
[Applause]
it was hungry too
and the guy's trying not to look he's
like uh
and so he's sitting on the couch right
and i go hey do you mind if i take a
look at the curriculum is it on that
clipboard he goes yeah yeah and i sat
down on the couch and you guys will know
what i'm talking about when i say this i
sat next to him
not too close but too close do you know
what i mean like
close enough where he noticed
and then i pretended like i was a little
out of breath from stretching
and he starts to read off the clipboard
and i do this is something my brother
taught me which is master class torture
he's reading and i just go like this
and i do it the first time
and i see him just do this
i just do one more
and i could tell i was getting to him
because he went just like this
which is him telling me i can [ __ ]
feel that
when i stand up i go well that sounds
that feels like a pretty solid
curriculum he goes yeah yeah we're
really gonna
you know i got a lot of good things
planned for him i go cool and i just
started to do this
and he's like what's going on i go well
you know i was gonna go to the gym but i
gotta wait here with you but you know
the guy who usually stretches me out
he's waiting for me at the gym
and when i get there you know he's my
trainer and i'm gonna he's not gonna
have time to stretch me out i go do you
mind helping me stretch out
before i go now here's the one thing if
you're not on the joke you're not you
know what you're not going to do if
you're a civilian you're not going to
touch me
if you're in on the joke you're going to
touch me
and i go will you help me stretch out
and he goes sure and i go cool i need
help with my hammies
and you know that stretch right you put
your leg up
and he pushes back right
so i put my leg up and he goes what do i
do i go just grab my ankle and just push
back slowly like that and he goes okay
and he starts to push back now guys
i don't want to say i can fart on demand
but i do usually have one in the chamber
just in case a gunfight breaks out dude
i mean
i don't want to be shooting blanks out
there but it didn't even mean you know
and look we're all grown up so you can
go
to pretend like you're grossed out but
i'm going to tell you something
look we've all been alive on this earth
long enough you know kind of by the
pressure
on your butthole what the fart's gonna
sound like do you know what i mean like
you can kind of tell if you need to be
by yourself or you can let it go at the
mall you know what i mean like
and so to me it felt like a you know
you know one of those
you know the one that hurts a little bit
on the way out you know
where you fart you're like like one of
those like like a
it's like someone's like a hot razor
blade was like
like there's a knife fight on your
butthole like steps
all right
so that's what it felt like you know and
the general rule of thumb is if it hurts
on the way out it's going to hurt
everybody else when he gets up
so i'm looking forward to it you know
and he starts to push on my leg
that's that's not what came out
he starts to push up my leg and then
just
yo it was like i was calling in
reinforcements on lord of the rings
[Music]
bringing the elves
calling the dwarves
you shall not pass
like one of those
and his hair was like
and this dude just backs up just like
this and he goes
he backs up and he goes what the [ __ ]
i go yeah i'm really sorry who is i'm
not stretching out that other hammy
so yeah i don't blame you
[Music]
night
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]